In this lesson, we're going to explore character dynamic lighting with Unreal.
So let's get started.
So setting it up.
When lighting characters try to use colors in the background that complement the character's tone.
With a character having a tan skin tone, peach, blue can complement them when placed behind them.
Now you'll see this in Love, Death and Robots, the Entombed project I worked with, Sony Imageworks and Unreal.
You'll see that there's a blue color back behind the characters, pretty consistent through most of the film.
But it works really well with these tan skin colors of most of the characters in the episode.
Now you'll notice I have some rim lighting in here too, which works really well.
And this overall and several of the shots that I worked on like this worked really well like that.
But you'll also notice there is a bit more shadow on one side of the face versus another.
So also for dynamic lighting, try to keep that line to one side of the face.
Now, again, you'll see it again on this image down below with a metahuman of myself.
This is available if you want to light this particular character in the baked project that I give you.
So you're more than welcome to.
We're going to mainly focus on Lumen when we light our character.
And we'll take a look at how you can do it and use some of the tools to get some of that really dramatic feel.
Now, again, it's always good to try to explore those areas with lighting on your character where you want one side a little bit darker than the other.
You will see in some shows like, you know, like, I don't know, soap operas and dramas where everything's kind of evenly lit.
I never really like that.
It's always better to get a little bit some sort of drama, even in those particular environments, some sort of dramatic feel for the light and for the camera.
Just to tell a good story and keep things interesting.
That's the artist side of me.
But again, it's all depending with your tools, with your shot.
Always explore and be creative and using your tools in a real can never be easier.
And again, you can see for each one of three of these shots, and this is the one called the Crimson Claw scene that will be lighting.
You'll notice there is a rim lighting here.
There's rim lighting here and there's rim lighting here.
All three that I've established and built.
Now, again, you can have some fun with this and explore it any way you want.
You don't necessarily have to light exactly like me.
But let's actually take a look at those tools in just a bit.
So one of the lights I'm going to point out that I use quite often is the rec light.
It is fantastic.
And you can't hear me speak enough about it.
It is the more expensive light.
So keep that in mind when you're either baking lights and we have character examples for baking.
And this one is included or whether you're using lumen.
Now, lumen is really efficient.
It can work really well.
But be aware of some of the noise that may occur due to your your shadows and the unreal trying to digest and calculate the GI on the camera.
So just be very deterministic and be careful and just be aware of them and move things around accordingly.
Now, again, lumen is evolving.
It's going to get better, faster, stronger or the noise can and will be eventually completely removed.
But for now, there's always going to be a little bit.
So be very strategic with your shots and how you place things in the world.
Let's go ahead and take a look at this in Unreal and you can go ahead and follow along and build things with me.
So in Unreal, we have our hero, the light.
In Unreal, we have our hero, the crimson claw.
You have to say it every time you say his name.
I'm going to say that deep.
You can see him fighting back the evil manys here, the mannequins or the man.
We say we call him Manny, the male's Manny and the female's Quinn.
So you can see him fighting them back, trying to get to him.
And you'll notice again, I have rim lighting.
I have some nice universal lighting in here.
You can even add more fill lights in here, but this is shows you a nice little base to be able to play with and to work with.
So let's actually light our own.
And I'm going to get you going in the right direction here.
So to do that, let's go to our content browser here and we're going to go ahead and open up our scene.
And we'll go to character lighting.
This is where you can grab this underneath the class name.
And then you'll see character lighting.
And I'm going to go ahead and grab on the start.
Let's go and click the start.
We really just have nothing but glowing objects in here.
And Lumen is working in that direction.
Now we can actually get them to be a lot more stronger in our influence for here.
But we got to add a few things such as Lumen GI and so forth.
So since we're using Lumen, we can go to our project settings and double check and make sure everything's on.
One, let's make sure our shader model six is active.
We can see it is active here, which is our primary.
And I also like to turn on the target shader formats here for Vulkan.
That actually helps, especially if you're bringing such things in.
Let's go to rendering.
Under rendering, let's double check.
We have Lumen.
We have Lumen reflections in here.
Surface catch, detailed ray tracing.
We can change these to to be more hit lighting for reflections.
You can actually change it in the post-process volume.
Virtual shadow maps supporting for ray tracing.
All these hit the checkboxes.
And we, again, mesh distance field is already active in here.
So if you want to look it up, you can.
You can say, hey, man, is my mesh distance field in here ready to go?
You really shouldn't have to.
And you'll see here, allow.
This is a little bit different.
We can see generate mesh distance field.
This is the one that you want in here.
Also, we should be good to go.
Everything should be rocking.
So let's go and get started with that.
Now, the glows in here are given off light.
You'll see that a little bit here on the head here.
The glow here is not too strong on the shield, but it's definitely something I could explore more if I wanted to.
Everything is grouped on him.
So you would have to ungroup him to change some of those items.
It just made it easier for me to place him in the world.
Let's go ahead and go to our tools here.
Actually, I should say Windows environment light mixer.
Let's go and create a skylight.
You'll get an error at first, but we've talked about this in previous classes.
We're going to create a volumetric to clear some of that out.
Create an atmospheric light.
Create a sky atmosphere.
You'll see that disappear.
Create a volumetric cloud and create a height fog.
There we go.
So let's go and rotate that light in the direction that we need.
So let's grab that directional light.
Let's move it into our scene a bit here.
It's pretty close by.
There he is.
Let's pull this up.
Now, if you want to, you can rotate this any way that you want.
We can make it look like it's a moonlit night and have a light kind of bleed across the hero's face.
And if we want to, we can lower this to like a five or two.
We can give it a bluish color like Hollywood does that.
Moonlight's always blue, right?
Not real light.
We can do that if you want to.
A little dramatic.
And we can go in here and soften things up a little bit with the source angle.
If the shadows aren't as blurry as we want.
But actually, these look pretty good.
They're pretty good.
So we can always revisit that if you want to.
We want to have a post-process volume.
Now, I have one already in here.
But again, put this in here as you need.
We can set this to lumen.
Set the method to lumen.
Also, we want hit reflection in here.
And we want to go in here and underneath lumen, low illumination, turn all these on as well as the advanced.
Now, start low and then go high.
Always remember that.
So I'm going to bump up the lumen scene quality and the lumen scene detail.
Now, again, these are expensive GPUs.
So if your computer is a little bit questionable, be careful with it.
Final Gather is going to help get rid of some of the noise that may occur.
You can see that there.
Unreal's even telling you that.
And I think we're in a good spot to be able to keep rolling and light things.
Now, we've covered some of that in other classes.
So explore as you need.
I don't want us to get too caught up with the details.
Because we do need to place lights in here.
So I'm going to pull in a rec light initially.
I'm going to rotate him and make sure he's not intersecting with geometry.
So there can be some noise that occurs.
That happens quite often with ray tracing because Unreal doesn't know where the photons begin and end.
I'm going to place this up into the scene.
I'm going to set this at a really low amount.
So we'll set this to like maybe a two.
And we can stretch this out.
And we can go ahead and set this to like a three.
Make sure you do it in the details and not anywhere else.
You can you can feel free to actually go in here and play with this a bit more with Alex.
Kind of cool.
Nice little highlights off his suit.
And you can determine whether you want shadows to come off this.
It's up to you.
So I'm going to do that a little bit dramatic.
I do want a little bit of that redness coming off his shield.
So I'm going to pull in and make sure that he's not intersecting with geometry.
And I'm going to go ahead and set this to like maybe a two.
And we can stretch this out.
Make sure you do it in the details and not anywhere else.
So I'm going to do that a little bit dramatic.
I do want a little bit of that redness coming off his shield.
So I'm going to pull in and make again, make sure your lights are movable so that the GI updates appropriately.
And I'm going to go and pull in a point light.
You may not think, oh, well, my my stationery is working.
No, you still want to do movable because anything you change in your post-process volume is going to make sense to Unreal.
If it's stationary, it will not make sense.
It will be very weird and Unreal will not obey and do what you want.
Your intentions will not be clear because you're not connecting a dynamic light with a dynamic GI setup.
You see, has a little EEC line going on for our hero.
Let's set this to like a two and make this red.
And actually, we can even make it lighter.
Seems like a little strong so we can make that maybe a point five.
There we go. Pretty cool.
A little different than what we had before.
I like this highlight better than my original.
It's pretty cool.
I got a little fog material on here.
Unreal did a nice little transition when I brought in the material from Maya.
It created a new to control that material made like a fog material.
There are a few limitations with that, but it's like a.
If we look at it.
Well, I won't bother looking at it, but if you did crack this up and you will see a material function buried in there, it's OK.
I like it for this particular case.
I think it looks fantastic.
But if you need to make some more details, you may want to swap that out and just adjust it and remove that material function and just use Unreal's materials from there using roughness and a few other things.
Quick material note.
Now let's go ahead and bump up a few things such as some dramatic lighting.
So I'm going to pull in some rec light, a rec light in here.
This rec light will rotate this.
Do a 90 degree rotate.
Move this back just a bit.
Get some cool rim lighting.
Move it up a little bit, stretch it out so it covers a little bit more.
Oh, that's nice.
And then we can lean that in just a tad.
We don't want it too strong, so we're going to set this to like maybe a three.
We could even do a four half the amount.
Tell it not to cast shadows.
And we can also tell this point light not to cast shadows either.
And again, make sure your lights are movable when you select them.
We're going to say don't cast shadows.
This also needs to be movable.
Set that to movable.
There we go. So far, so great.
Do we want this to cast shadows? Yeah, it's kind of cool.
It actually works pretty well, so we can leave that.
We're going to need a few more rec lights in here and I'm going to need maybe one more here to get a dramatic shadow in the face.
So let's pull on another rec light.
Again, they are expensive, so keep those things in mind.
Move this over.
Move this up.
Change the source width.
Notice it changes the energy.
Change the source height.
Set this to like a two.
And maybe even lower. Let's do a .5.
And if we want, we can fake this like moonlight. What?
Make it slightly blue.
Even more blue if you want. It's up to you.
And even take this to a one if you want at that point.
Or a two. Or a three.
It's up to you.
Pretty cool. Pretty cool.
A little blue casting behind him, which will work great with the skin.
Oh my.
I don't want every light in here to cast shadow, so we definitely can turn that one off too.
So now we got our villains we want to handle.
And we can probably lower the highlight of the suit to a one.
There you go. Or maybe even a two.
Let me see. 1.5. I think will work. 1.5.
There we go. All happy medium.
We're going to do one more fill light for the whole scene.
So let's do some rim lights. I'll keep it pretty brief because we don't want this to be too long of a lecture.
I'm going to go ahead and pull on a rec light.
And we'll do a source width.
Do a bit of a source height.
A little more of a width because we can get this more of a narrow highlight.
Ooh, that's kind of cool.
Almost like a Jack Kirby highlight.
I know I'm such a comic nerd.
Oh, let me do controls here for a second.
Turn it this way.
Change the width a little bit.
Lower it.
Set it to now object rotation versus world.
Don't cast shadows.
Lower that strength and like one could even do a little bit stronger.
I'll leave that for now.
Because we'll do another fill light here over here.
Just a little one.
Now, if you brought in, say, a point light, you're like, oh, I need to fill this a little bit.
You got to be careful. Hot spots have a shiny object here.
So you can use it. And again, remember, we talked about this.
You can lower the spec so the shape doesn't show up or you can go in here and control the source soft source radius.
So we can bump that up a little bit so it doesn't quite affect things too much because we want it to fill not necessarily take up space.
And we can set this to one.
And move it up a little bit.
And it can be a nice little fill light there.
You can determine where you want to put it.
What a highlight a little bit more.
Rec lights are always a little bit better for this, but I just thought I'd put a point line in just to show you a bunch of tools to play with.
All right. So we want to do a little rim lighting for him and a little fill lights for him.
So let's go pull out another rec light.
We can change that color whatever we want for this particular character.
There we'll have it facing him. Change the width.
Change the strength.
Rotate it.
Oh, that's nice.
We got like a nice little rim lighting off this character here.
Turn off the shadows. No casting the shadows for that.
And in this particular one where we have the rec light here we can even move this in a little closer.
And if we do, we can get maybe a little more highlights on that limb that he has his limbs fading back there.
So I could do something like this.
Like this, just by positioning things.
There we go.
Now we're getting quite as dramatic as are my example here.
So what we can do if we wanted to is bump this up a little bit more.
Kind of do like it a little bit stronger. That's up to you.
Makes the robots seem like they've taken over a little mood lighting in here.
Or we can even lower that down to maybe a one if you wanted to.
And our directional light, if that's an issue, lower it some more.
Put it to one here. So our primary lights are environment.
And then we can take some of these and dumb them down even more.
Point five here.
And we can make this one too.
It's up to you. And then now we can crank this one up maybe a little bit more.
And again, you can change the mood of all your colors if you want.
Whatever you want to do.
And you can see dramatically this really has a good vibe.
So you can play with these any way you want.
I think a bluish gray works pretty well.
Even more extreme blue too. Pushing blue a little bit farther.
Now if we change this to more of a white,
you'll see it changes the complete feel for this scene.
Dramatic, not so dramatic.
You can see that.
Now if we want shadows on these at any time, you can add them.
So we can say I want to cast a shadow here.
That actually helps the TVs.
A more believable feel to them.
And again, when you bring in these lights, switch it to movable.
Notice they're coming in stationary.
Directional by default will become movable, but the others will not.
Make sure you click on that.
So finally in here, I think we're at a good spot.
If we wanted to, we could even make it a bit darker.
Just by changing these values, you'll notice changing these just a little bit can help with the look and feel that you need.
Again, all of these are relating to the world.
So if at any time you want to bring in the shadows, you can.
They may help or may not.
Office lighting obviously will give you more shadows as you play with these.
As you pull them in, you'll see them come in here, make things a little more grounded and believable.
They will remove highlights too, so be careful with that.
And finally, if we wanted to, we can actually put in one more very low rec light right beside his head.
Rotate this.
Move it up for more dramatic feel.
Change that width.
And change that strength.
We'll do that.
We'll do something like a one to test it out.
It kind of looks like an animated series there.
We can move it closer to his face.
And this particular rec light here, we can lower this one so it doesn't has less of an influence over there.
Now, this is really up to you how you want to do this.
And you can also change the dramatic positioning.
Of our light here.
And then we can lower some of the other ones in here as a whole.
And move things around as you need.
That way your characters don't get lost.
And we can also probably add one more rim lighting here for the robot.
Move that in.
Move it across.
And let's switch that to object.
So it's a little easier to move around.
And we could change that to like a pink color.
Look like he got shot with electric pink death.
I'm pretty sure that's the name of his weapon.
It could be.
We just open this up.
Set this to a two.
There you go.
And then again, we can mess with our barn door angle.
So we can make that a little more focused.
Or opened up.
Move it down.
And even rotate this towards them.
So they both look like they got shot.
Cool.
So I hope this helped you guys out on different approaches you can do.
Again, make sure it's movable.
And you can play with your lights.
You can make any scene that you want as dramatic as you want.
Just have some fun with it.
And if I hit the G key, you can see everything within its intended look and feel.
And we did this all in real time.
We aren't getting much noise, which is fantastic.
We also could play with some of the reflectivity here.
You'll notice in the post process volume.
If you go back to the post process one, just type it in.
You want to make sure that you are using your reflectivity with lumen.
But also in your project settings, we can go in here under rendering.
And I'll make it so you can see this a bit better.
We can go in here and say, move down here underneath reflections.
We're using.
Go down here.
Where do you want to go here?
We can change like hit reflections and then we have detailed.
Tracing again, you can do that within your post process volume too,
so you can get things in the right direction.
So this is going to give us like the best possible detail for our reflections.
And again, keeping things lumen is going to be super, super, super helpful.
And with ray tracing active and so forth.
All right, so that's about it with this one.
And again, if you have any questions at the end of our courses,
and let's actually turn high transition reflections here and turn that one on.
You'll see a little bit of shift.
If you have any other questions on these, let us know.
And we'll be there to help you and get you going in the right direction when it comes to Unreal.
For further exploration with Unreal, you can actually look at our characters
that are nested inside the bake lighting folder and the big lighting scene.
And you can play with some of the things there.
Keep in mind, they are more focused on baking.
So feel free to convert the whole thing into lumen and play with them a bit farther
and see what kind of results you get.
Here's some credits again for all those that have worked on this project.
And here's some of the things that we've done.
So that's all we have for now.
We hope you enjoyed this video.
If you did, please like, share, and subscribe.
And if you haven't already, you can click on this project.
And here are some additional resources link,
a link here that you guys can click on and jump into these topics a lot more deeper.
Thanks again for being part of the class.
In the next video, we'll just recap everything we've learned.
And that's it.